bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti la
roba nei musei simulator x che alla fine
si tratta di questo ricordiamo a tutti
quanti che la cosa più preziosa da
trovare nel museo e il foglietto con la
password del canale dei miei contro te
quindi se riusciamo a toccare a parlare
quello
siamo a posto ci sarà un mini tutorial a
curva cacchio un lago non sia mancata
una volta hanno quella dove sono
arrivato va bene questo il museo notti
fa vederla entrata ma bellissimo ci fa
vedere dove sovente rai per primo allora
vediamo se riscattare subito la scala
mi sembra di giocare ad uncharted una
versione in prima persona dove cioè i
poteri di static shock qualcuno lo
guardava quando era piccoli o lo andavo
era una notizia che girava con lo
skateboard dai fulmini alle persone come
omaggio
sono tornato tutto indietro alla fine
era fatto un giro inuti analitici e
questo per disabilità nella videocamera
e aprile però che aprì lo devo
elettrizzare questo aspetto allora che
si ricarica madonna che gioco complicato
cavallo pazzo fanno fatto fatto dai
corni prima che i tifosi tutti i siti
perfetto l'ho fatta
calmati adesso il giudizio calmati ok ho
fatto un metro e basta però buon inizio
almeno teoricamente non ho ben capito
allora qui c'è un altro pur christian
ogni volta che si ricarica sta roba mi
più male
teoricamente se io vado adesso seguire
il cavo il cavo della videocamera
passati limited che non sai d'età devo
seguire eccolo laggiù
devo prima disabilità dalla videocamera
e poi posso andare avanti ma che ha
quindi un gioco è veramente difficile
adesso ragazzi mi conviene guardare su
amazon se esiste sto quanto perché posso
andare alle partite di calcio senza
pagarle in realtà perché perché adesso
non puoi andare però in generale appena
si anche al cinema centri la
biglietteria storni c il
bigliettaio fantastico ce l'ho fatta
sono dentro check points rubando dei
soldi random senza un motivo però la
bella ragazza è utile questo condotto
d'areazione comunque cambia proprietaria
la stanza cacchio chi è il genio inedite
di dove stiamo andando ragazzi perché io
teoricamente non sto seguendo un le
polaroid cioè dove si sa dove dovrebbe
essere stop avevano visto niente finora
non ve lo riconosco anche la fontana la
fontana della prima polaroid
ok quindi siamo più o meno all'inizio
ancora sono al piano di sopra l'aria non
ho capito ma sto punto se vuoi
l'approvvigionamento approvvigionamenti
per levico in arrivo arriva lieti tuor e
va bene
dipende da quanto devo salire ancora
mannaggia il cacchio ma l'ascensore per
ladri potete metterlo o cacchio c'è
gente cioè noise maker omega noise maker
tedesche noise maker alla fine lancio
una palla e non è che lo fanno passare
come tecnologia avanzata incredibile e
una palla che sto lanciando le niente di
tra però cappellini alla moda google
galles gadget serve ancora un briefing
ma non ho capito sinceramente in che
senso
va bene ho fatto dei giri allucinanti ma
in tutto sto casino non ho capito dove
devo anche una videocamera di utenti non
ho capito dove devo andare in tutto sto
guardando a questa gira però vedo che
gira ma chi se ne frega no porca vacca
forse mi salvo forse mi salvo forse mi
salvo non si aiuta tutti store disco ce
l'ho fatta solo fenomeno ma sono in
grande cacchio vi volevo buttare giù
tantissimo doveva far niente ma i cori
dato è stordito lo zio cioè non so per
quanto come ha fatto poi ad allertare
tutti non è
liberati come faccio a scendere intanto
sta ancora parlando ma cosa sta parlando
ma è stordito non è possibile
porca vacca devo fare
ma quello è salito li ama cacchio sono
stupido forte a ok meno male che l'hai
detto tu dove devo passare il sì perché
sono mica lo capivo d'altro
dov'è andato s'è suicidato dopo dov'è ma
così succede eccolo è bravo saranno
esattamente dove volevo andare il
fantastico come l'impalcatura mi porta
esattamente 2 voglio io avanti un ottimo
anche qui c'è una finestra sugli che c'è
porca vacca
mannaggia volo stordirlo il problema è
che non mi aspettavo fosse le talent è
rivolto verso di me pochi ragazzi di
fatto il giro teoricamente ci dovremmo
essere stavolta se non vedo nessuno il
corridoio perfetto o eccola il quadro è
il quadro mica il vaso
l'italiano allora c'è una videocamera
bello però mettiamoli bene in vista i
così la videocamera i quadri elettrici
dei geni siete allora prova a vedere
dove devo disabilitare ste videocamere
anche se questo qua è coperto dalla
tenda o che allora uno è lì e l'altro e
nell'altra stanza proprio la devo fare
prima così pac e uno veloce però ok
eccola andato quindi una volta fatto
questo io vado qua devo andare
nell'altra dell'altra stanza proprio
perché devo disabilitare l'altro che sta
esattamente qui sopra perfetto veloce
caricati dai cacchio madonna che
mestiere difficile effetto
e mo niente rubo del vaso e basta alla
faccia del vetro ma come lo disabilitate
cosa ma leo ton the nation cup sono
tolte addio buttato di unione ne frega
niente ne vado
c'è l'uscita di ok alla prosa unici lo
allucinante ragazzi non so se riesco non
buttarti giù di qua carchiolo come mai
scattato la come mai ragazzi è scattato
l'allarme disabilitato tutto l'anno ma
forse perché quello è l'allarme di come
si dice che il rilevamento di pressione
che va a fare lì per forza a provocare
cosa da che for more
ok
dimmi che se si girato l'inglese girato
si è girato per culo via via via via via
via via via via via via perfetto ma
bravo bravo non è scattata l'allerta
pipelet aspetto stretto aspetti aspetti
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
cazzo il cosa risotto ma [ __ ]
domanda era che allora proviamo l'altra
strada facciamo prima
e allora tanto che hanno ammiccato
faccio il giro dall'altra parte degenza
assenso 12 giri 46 da calcio dove
troviamo vedere se crescente di qualche
scelta mi sono anche dove sto andando
ormai non dovrei fare il primo al piano
di fuga e poi rubare il cosap e che se
non si scende manco per il caso c'è
gente di roma che cacchio scherzavo devo
fare tutto un altro giro la meglio
teoricamente cia dovrei fare ragazzi ci
provai la videocamera lì da attimo in
tutto giù di judy qualche effetto
vai vai vai veloce cosa what sarà corto
uno non se n'è accorto
minchia meno male ok
store di cirò molto bene solo adesso c'è
la videocamera lì che faccio oppure
vankor hanno aspettato videocamere
storta 1 storta
adesso si muove la videocamera brava o
cazzo ci sono ci sono ci sono
ce l'ho fatta mato mato è stato orribile
ragazzi ho avuto un anziana donna meno
le facevo youtuber meno male signori
spero che video vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un commento è vi piace fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate delle mie abilità
da del mio scheda ladro anche se
effettivamente non è il mio mestiere
noi ci crediamo come sempre ad un
professionista ragazzi
[Musica]